So today in class,
we were talking about culture,
diversity, and leadership,
and unfortunately,
students said,
let's look at some of the companies
and where we get information.
I said, let's go to apple and look at their website.
And so when you go to Apple's executive leadership team,
literally just scroll to the bottom.
Tell me what you notice. Go ahead.
So I got to introduce the term pale,
stale in male
to a group of students who hadn't heard it before.
And I love that it was not what we expected,
because you've also given other examples of companies
that are actively trying to make their
leadership look like,
for example,
the customers.
This is a very diverse class. That said,
raise your hand if you own an apple product.
The entire room of people of all different backgrounds.
We have apple products,
but apple does not look like the world that it serves.
Is it a problem?
You tell me.